four suspects in custody tonight after  three people were shot near charleston  and las vegas boulevard  investigators say it started with an  incident at a nearby convenience store  that when police arrived they found the  shooting victims then they chased  the suspect's car the driver of that car  hit two people near d.i and swenson  and at that point authorities took those  suspects into custody  now we talked to one neighbor who says  that area near charleston and the  boulevard  it's pretty busy it's always been a  powder keg  there's always a lot of people  congregate on these corners especially  you know groups of 10 15 people in these  parking lots at all times  now as for the two people that were hit  by the car they did not need treatment